WAS NOT PARTICULARLY INCLINED IN
THE RULING HERE AND HE WITH MORN
THIS BREAKING NEWS, DO GOING FOR
THE PRESIDENT, IS THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY,
JAY SEKULOW.
JAY, WHAT YOU HAVE?
>> LOOK, THIS IS AS YOU JUST SAY
HUGE.
IT WAS BASICALLY THE DNC'S TRIAL
OF THE RUSSIA HOAX.
THEY BASICALLY TOOK THIS WHOLE
WIKILEAKS INQUIRY THAT WENT ON
AND TRIED TO TURN IT INTO A
FEDERAL LAWSUIT.
A JUDGE APPOINTED BY
BILL CLINTON WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT SAID THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS ARE DIVORCED FROM
THE FACTS FOR THE EVIDENCE
DOESN'T SUPPORT THE ALLEGATIONS.
THEY ALSO RAISED SERIOUS ISSUES
INVOLVING THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH,
FREEDOM OF ASSOCIATION, SO WHAT
YOU HAVE HERE IS AN ATTEMPT BY
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE TO LITIGATE THE
FEDERAL COURT, ALLEGATIONS OF
RUSSIA COLLUSION, RUSSIA
CONSPIRACY, INVOLVING THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, NOT ONLY AS A
PROJECTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN THE MUELLER REPORT
BUT IT'S REJECTED BY A FEDERAL
COURT JUDGE, AS HIS HEAD,
APPOINTED BY THE FEDERAL
CLINTON, WHO THROWS THE CASE OUT
AND SAYS, NO EVIDENCE.
THE EVIDENCE WAS DIVORCED FROM
THE ALLEGATIONS.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT WOULD BACK
UP WHAT THEY ASSERTED.
SO THIS IS A VERY, VERY
SIGNIFICANT WHEN IN FEDERAL
COURT.
A VERY SIGNIFICANT WIN FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK I'M A LOOK.
THIS WAS THE INQUIRY OF THIS
WHOLE RUSSIA HOAX.
THEY COULDN'T WIN ON A COLLUSION
EIGHT CONSPIRACY, THEY CAN WIN
ON INSTRUCTION, SO IN A CIVIL
LITIGATION, IN FEDERAL COURT,
AGAINST THE CAMPAIGN, HIS WHERE